I began to watch closely what I was saying.
I do not know whether this is intentional or not.
But I felt a rash grow in my mind and spirit.
Some of my students told me that the same thing had happened to them yet
Listen to some of the articles I have explained to you.
Divided into two parts,
To move ... I was the old one who most talked
I like arguments and ideas, and another part watched the first with open eyes
He is tried impartially. The latter was watching first and saying, "That's not your idea"
"You do not really think so"
"I'm not really learning what you're saying"
"That's not true."
I found it very interesting. Since that happens
With 95 percent of what I say, I did not know what to do. I said well, this is strange. Maybe
Broken, not that good. I did not hear sounds or anything like that.
I mean, it was not.
I've had ... well, people have several parts.
I was going through a strange puzzle. Which two are I? Is it the part that listens and then says:
"No, that's nonsense." "this is a lie". "This..."
"You do it to excite people," "You just want to win the controversy."
Whether that's the part I was released from
My usual verbal? I did not know. But I decided to choose a critic.
What I tried and learned to do, I think,
Is to stop saying things that made me weak.
I still try to do it, because I always do
I feel as I speak,
Whether what I say makes me consistent or divided
I think the consistency
It's the best way to imagine it, because I think you're saying things
As true as you can, they come
From the depths within you, because we do not know the source of ideas. We do not know how deep
In our internal structure generate ideas. We do not know any operations
Physiological consistency required to speak from the very core of your being. We do not understand either.
I do not even imagine it, but I believe you can feel it, and I learned some from my reading of Karl Rogers
A great clinical psychologist, speaking of mental health as being partly interconnected
Between spiritual or abstract, and physical. And that the two are consistent. There is a lot
On the consistency of analytical and clinical psychological thought. On each, I decided to start
Practice not to say things that make me weak. What happened is that I am
I had to stop saying
Almost everything you say. 95 percent in my estimation
Over a few months,
It was very shocking, to wake up and realize that you are almost a dead branch!
It's a shock! You may ask: "Do you really want all that to fade?"
Only 5% of you are left.
If those 5% ... well established,
So maybe that's exactly what it wants to happen
I told you that that story is a detail of the verse: "The Lord saw that the evil of man had multiplied in the earth,
And that every conceivable thought of his heart is evil every day. "
Question worthy of answer:
"What are your motives exactly?"
Perhaps it is cleaner than my motives, and this is certainly possible.
I do not think I'm a good person, exactly, by nature.
I think I have to work hard on this, and I do not think all people necessarily do
But some people are worse than that, and everyone is pretty well.
So it's worth thinking about.
Exactly, how much trouble do you want to cause?
You may also think, if you do not do something important in your life, according to your own definition,
- That's the game we're playing - you're the one who sets the rules, at least initially,
You may be inclined to make trouble just because you do not know otherwise.
Because trouble at least more exciting than boredom! That's what you learn if you read to Dostoevsky.
Dostoevsky knew that well.
So if you do not do anything. If you do not pay yourself within your limits
You'll have plenty
Of will, energy, and resources to devote them to causing dramatic trouble.
Also, I think this is a classic scenario.
"And the Lord saw that the wickedness of man was abundant in the earth, and that every conceivable thought of his heart was evil every day."
That is something worth pondering.
This is not self-destruction
Because in fact trying ... it's like diagnosing a disease
The coincidence that it applies to you to some extent
Maybe it's 10% of you, or maybe 90%
So, you are treated as excellent, because then you may stop doing so.
The negative side of it?
You must leave your resentment, of course, your hatred and all that.
This is really annoying, because these feelings make it very easy to practice.
It is fun, with a sense of accompaniment.
But,
You do not do this to harden yourself with criticism,
But to distinguish the nausea from the fat, and leave all the money you would like to be behind you.